you can trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people on the
back like 50 times
why never do it again asgard's resident
god of mischief is back with his own
disney plus series and it looks like
it's gonna be bonkers i'm carlos
bustamante and let's break down that new
loki trailer shall we
tom hiddleston is back as the fan
favorite character who slipped away with
the tesseract and avengers end game and
i can't be the only one who's excited to
see
how this variant on the mcu timeline
will affect future appearances
by the norse god right we protect
the proper flow of time the series which
looks like it will be even more of a
mind bender than wand division will
introduce the time
variance authority an organization
responsible for overseeing the
multiverse and has the power to at least
in the comics
actually end entire timelines you picked
up the tesseract breaking reality
i want you to help us fix it and in
order to do that
it looks like loki or at least a version
of loki has got to bounce around a bunch
of different realities
here's some standouts real quick an
alternate version of new york where
avengers tower and the city have been
totally leveled loki
looking kind of presidential and a clear
nod to the vote loki comic
and this hotly debated shot which some
believe
is loki sitting with black widow on
vormir
though it could also very well be lady
loki who we think we've seen in some set
photos
played by sophia dimartino so whether
it's time traveling dimension hopping or
both
loki better mind his manners because the
tva is always watching
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said
this is absurd
[Music]
sign this too owen wilson plays mobius
m mobius the bureaucratic counterpart to
loki's off the rails demigod and i
have to say it's pretty charming in part
big metaphor guy
i love it makes you sound super smart i
am smart
i know okay okay google and bacharach is
here as well and it looks like she'll be
playing a little good cop bad cop with
owen wilson's character
mummy musaku and richard e grant are
also featured in mysterious roles
though can we just all agree if we're
still looking at mephisto to be in one
of these things
richard's the guy right i mean come on
though with the obvious nod to rocks on
and the abundant
time jumping the other two villains who
could debut here
are evil roxon ceo slash actual minotaur
dario agar
and classic avengers villain the time
traveling kang the conqueror
so what did you think of the new trailer
loki starts streaming june 11 on disney
plus
share your thoughts and mephisto
theories oh and sliders and back to the
future references
in the comments below and be sure to
check back with us on friday for our
falcon and the winter soldier episode 4
recap
see you next time
you